madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues ayant été moindre
tout d'abord de vous présenter mes
meilleurs voeux pour cette nouvelle
année 2021 vendredi dernier le logiciel
erp du réseau public de transport
d'électricité rte dont l'une des
missions est d'assurer l'équilibré entre
l'offre et la demande est restée active
et le signal rouge au niveau national
rte inciter les français à réduire leur
consommation d'électricité en appliquant
des gestes des écogestes cet épisode
témoigne de notre situation très
vulnérable pour cet hiver il y aura
n'était rien d'étonnant il est
d'ailleurs probable qu'ils se réitère
avec les conséquences peut-être plus
grave d'ici la fin mars
et pourtant si le sénat avait été
entendu plus tôt cet épisode aurait sans
doute pu être évité
depuis bientôt un an le secteur de
l'énergie et singulièrement le marché
lire si c est entrer dans une véritable
zone de turbulences au delà de son
impact sanitaire la crise de lakovic 19
à de lourdes répercussions sur notre
système énergétique
cette crise affecte l'aude man 2 est
l'un des frères titien en particulier
edf car elle réduit le niveau de la
demande et des prix des énergies ainsi
que la disposition des moyens de
production
selon l' agence internationale de
l'électricité la crise acolytes 19
les mesures de confinement qui ont ce
ont résulté quand on impact hors du
commun sur le système énergétique
dans ce contexte dès le 11 juin dernière
thé à anticiper une situation de
vigilance particulière pour l'hiver 20
2020 2021
cette situation sera d'autant plus
critique que des conditions
métérologiques seront rieuse s explique
essentiellement par indisponibilité
historiquement basses du parc nucléaire
sur les 58 réacteurs de ce parc neuf
seront arrêtés en février et 5 en mars
en effet la crise de la commune
entraîner des reports dans leurs
programmes d'arrêt de tranche d'edf
c'est à dire des opérations de
maintenance des centrales
par ailleurs certains réacteurs sont
indisponibles pour des raisons liées à
leur sûreté flamanville palluel budget
pire d'autres réacteurs ont été arrêtés
pour des considérations politiques
avec la fermeture de deux réacteurs de
la centrale de fessenheim en mars et
juin dernier le gouvernement a privé la
france d'une puissance de production de
1,8 giga watts ce qui représente mille
huit cents éoliennes de 1 mégawatt ou
quinze centrales thermiques de 150
mégawatts
nous n'avons pas fini d'en payer les
conséquences cette situation de
vigilance particulière sera très
sensible au mois de février et de mars
de même que dans le grand ouest
je pense particulièrement la région
bretagne qui est une véritable péninsule
car le déploiement de la centrale
nucléaire de flamanville n'a pas succédé
à l'extinction de la centrale à charbon
de cordemais cette situation perdurera
au moins jusqu'en 2023
notre parc de production d'électricité
des gens mais sans aucune capacité
supplémentaire en effet avec les
fermetures de centrales nucléaires et
thermiques ou nos moyens de production
se sont réduits sans être compensé par
l'essor des énergies renouvelables aux
effacements de consommation
cette situation se traduit par un
recours accru aux centrales thermiques
en france mais aussi à l'étranger
nous allons dépendre des apports
d'énergie de nos voisins européens à
commencer l'allemagne dont je rappelle
40% de la production d'électricité et de
sources fossiles ce regrettable pour
notre indépendance énergétique lorsque
l'on sait que la france fût
traditionnellement exportatrice
d'électricité
c'est regrettable pour nos engagements
climatiques lorsque l'on sait que les
trois quarts de notre production
d'exister sont entièrement décarbonée
cette situation ne conduira pas à un
complet black out c'est à dire une
coupure d'aix au cinéma nationalement
mais nécessitera à l'activation des
mécanismes dits post-marché
l'interruption des consommateurs
industriels la baisse de tension sur le
réseau l'aspect l'appel aux gestes
citoyens surtout rte n'exclut pas des
coupures d'exciter séquencé et contrôler
les français n'ont pas fini d'être
sollicité par des appels aux gestes
citoyens
si ces gestes sont sans doute
appréciable ils ne font pas une
politique énergétique madame la ministre
les français sont en droit d'attendre de
la part de nos gouvernements une terrine
au stick lucide des objectifs réalistes
et des mesures fortes
tout d'abord
le gouvernement doit poser un diagnostic
lucide sur la situation que nous
traversons lors de son audition devant
la commission des affaires économiques
en novembre dernier
madame la ministre verner à pompe il y
avait indiqué que notre vue numéral y
militer en matière de sécurité
d'approvisionnement était lié à la
prépondérance de l'énergie nucléaire
dans notre mix électrique
elle avait affirmé je cite 75 % de notre
électricité est produite à partir du
nucléaire quand il y à un raté sur le
nucléaire on en subit les conséquences
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
diversifier notre mix électrique afin
d'être moins à la merci de ce genre
d'aléas en pouvant faire appel à
d'autres types de production d'énergie
pour ma part je fais le constat
exactement inverse
c'est bien plutôt parce que nous n'avons
pas suffisamment investi dans l'énergie
nucléaire que nous en sommes arrivés à
cette situation
si les énergies renouvelables doit être
promue et j'en suis le premier convaincu
elles ne sont pas d'un grand secours
pour faire face à la pointe de
consommation hivernale compte tenu de
leur intermittence
faute d'un soutien suffisant à la
filière nucléaire ce sont aujourd'hui
les centrales thermiques de surcroît
étrangères qui tourne à plein régime
non des panneaux solaires ou des
éoliennes sous mais soumise est soumis
aux aléas climatiques
par ailleurs le gouvernement doit fixer
des objectifs réalistes pour sécuriser
notre approvisionnement l'examen de la
loi énergie climat dont je fus lance
rapporteur j'avais regretté le manque
d'anticipation des conséquences de la
politique énergétique menée je continue
de penser que la fermeture de quatre
centrales charbon d'ici 2022 et de 14
réacteurs nucléaires d'ici 2035 aurait
dû être davantage évalués par le
gouvernement au regard des notamment de
son impact sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement
par ailleurs à l'initiative de la
commission la commission des affaires
économiques du sénat législateur a
adopté un objectif d'au moins 6 et 8
gigawatts de capacités d'effacement
d'ici 2024
8 le compte n'y est pas puisque
aujourd'hui nous avons atteint seulement
un tiers et que sur le dernier appel
d'offres
il n'a été remplie coquard ce même souci
d'anticipation pour lequel je plaide
devra présider présidé à l'examen du
projet de loi issu des travaux de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
il faut se défier des mesures n'ayant
pas l'objet d'une complète étude
d'impact nous n'avons la preuve et
madame la ministre
c'est vraiment important de se mettre
dans la tête à cet égard
l'interdiction de facto des chaudières à
gaz dans les logements neufs à partir du
1er juillet prochain
issu des réglementations
environnementales 2020 il me semble tout
à fait prématuré car insuffisamment
évalué enfin le gouvernement doit
prendre des mesures fortes sur le plan
de la sécurité d'approvisionnement
la commission des affaires économiques
n'a cessé d'avancer des solutions afin
de maîtriser la consommation d'énergie
l'intensif qui l'attend signification
des appels d'offres en matière
d'effacement le rehaussement du chèque
énergie pour les ménages en situation de
précarité énergétique
le renforcement des dispositifs de
soutien à la rénovation énergétique
notamment en matière de régulation et de
programmation nous avons fait adopter
des amendements en ce sens dès le
premier collectif budgétaire en mars
2020 le gouvernement n'a conservé ses
aucune de ces solutions de bon sens nous
avons aussi demandé à ce que le
parlement soit associée aux travaux
stratégique de l'exécutif
s'agissant des réformes du marché
difficile en particulier celle de la
reine celle du groupe edf le
gouvernement nous a opposé une fin de
non recevoir votre salle je suis
convaincu que l'énergie d'un domaine
trop important pour être laissé à des
décisions hasardeuses mal calibré car
mal évalué le risque de black out que
nous vivons nous le rappelle aujourd'hui
cruellement la production d'énergie
nucléaire est en france un service
public une mission régalienne et
conditionne tout à la fois notre vie
sociale notre vie économique et notre
transition écologique sans elle et il
est illusoire d'atteindre la neutralité
carbone horizon 2050 madame la ministre
que compte faire le gouvernement pour
garantir la sécurité d'approvisionnement
cet hiver et au delà et de l'avenir du
nucléaire et du edf dans notre pays je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
madame mais rangé rabat secrétaire
d'état chargé de la biodiversité vous
avez la parole également pour une durée
de huit minutes maximum
les personnes en dessous surtout il en
soit merci madame la présidente mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs permettez moi
tout d'abord de vous présenter mes
meilleurs voeux pour cette année 2021 et
nous souhaitons tous effectivement que
cette année soit celle de la de la
résilience et de de l'apaisement pour
tous les français alors notre pays
risque t'il le black out électrique
notre système de production et
d'acheminement d'électricité est il en
mesure de répondre aux pointes de
consommation hivernale la fermeture de
la centrale nucléaire de fessenheim
met-elle en danger notre capacité à
fournir de l'énergie à toute heure et en
tous lieux
allons nous enfin avoir recours aux
centrales à charbon pour passer le cap
hivernale ce sont autant de questions
que le groupe l'est républicain nous
invite à examiner aujourd'hui dans le
cadre de ce débat un débat qui est
légitime
une une inquiétude qui n'est pas
forcément partagée mais qui en tout cas
appelle notre attention
donc je salue ce débat dans cet
hémicycle tout en vous disant et je vais
vous exprimer pourquoi je ne crois pas
que nous risquions un black out je ne
crois pas non plus que la fermeture de
fessenheim menace la stabilité de notre
système électrique
je crois que l'accroissement des
énergies renouvelables contribuer à
sécuriser notre approvisionnement
électrique que nous utiliserons de moins
en moins nos centrales à charbon et que
si nous faisons effectivement face à une
situation de vigilance particulière
nous sommes prêts à faire face aux pics
de consommation que nous que nous
connaissons si nous faisons face à une
situation de vigilance
c'est avant tout en raison de l'impact
de la pandémie
vous le savez en temps normal le
calendrier de maintenance de notre parc
nucléaire qui fournit 70 % de notre
électricité est organisée pour maximiser
la disponibilité des réacteurs en hiver
la crise sanitaire
cependant contraint edf à revoir ce
calendrier et le calendrier certaines
opérations de maintenance edf à notre
demande a révisé la planification des
arrêts de réacteurs afin d'améliorer
autant possible la disponibilité du parc
en hiver malgré ces malgré ces décalages
nous avons en outre demandé à rte de
mener des analyses prévisionnelles pour
évaluer la sécurité de
l'approvisionnement électrique au cours
des prochains mois et les conclusions de
ces analyses elles ont été rendues
publiques vous en avez pris connaissance
j'en suis persuadé elles sont
rassurantes la situation pour cet hiver
est plus favorable que nous laisse
comptions au printemps et ce du fait de
l'optimisation du planning d'art est
serré acteurs de la gestion prudente de
ces derniers mois de la production
hydroélectrique qui a permis de
constituer un stock supérieure aux
dernières années et d'une consommation
électrique qui est largement en deçà du
niveau habituel à la même époque
malheureusement en répercussion des
difficultés économiques que traverse
notre pays
je peux donc vous l'assuré ici les
français les françaises seront
approvisionnés sans difficulté et nous
ne risquons aucun black out c'est bien
sur le fondement des prévisions de rte
que nous pouvons l'affirmer je veux
d'ailleurs à cette occasion salué
l'implication des agents d'edf et de rte
qui sont à pied d'oeuvre pour que nous
soyons correctement approvisionnés ils
le sont si si je vous assure et jeu est
gelée je les salue
ce n'est qu'en cas de vague de froid
rigoureux et inhabituelle si la
température devenait sensiblement
inférieures aux normales de saison de
plusieurs degrés en moyenne pendant
plusieurs jours consécutifs qu'un point
de vigilance subsisterait et même dans
ce cas plusieurs leviers peuvent être
mis en oeuvre pour assurer cette
continuité d'approvisionnement
si nécessaire dans un premier temps en
collaboration avec certaines entreprises
la consommation peut être réduite
c'est l'effacement on l'a connue jeudi
dernier qui dans le
le volume disponible est doublé grâce
aux mesures qui sont mises en oeuvre
cette année
ensuite la consommation de certains
industriels peut être momentanément
arrêtée celle interruptible it est un
dispositif auquel ils souscrivent et
pour lequel ils sont rémunérés et si
cela ne suffisait pas rte peu diminué de
5% sur de courtes périodes l'attention
sur les réseaux les effets sont
quasiment imperceptible pour les
consommateurs enfin tout en restant tout
à fait improbable en dernier recours
parce que nous sommes aussi préparés aux
situations exceptionnelles
nous pourrions tout à fait procéder à
des opérations de délestage temporaire
du réseau il s'agirait alors en
prévenant les personnes concernées au
préalable de couper l'alimentation
électrique à un nombre limité de foyers
pour protéger l'ensemble du réseau et ce
pour une durée maximum de deux heures
nous ne serons donc en aucun cas
confrontés à des situations de blackout
donc de coupures massives et non
contrôlés sur le réseau et la sécurité
de notre approvisionnement garanti
électrique est tout à fait garanti alors
sur la question de la part du nucléaire
dans notre mix électrique je ne crois
pas non plus que la fermeture de
fessenheim augmente le risque pesant sur
le réseau électrique
vous avez parlé de
de mesures de calcul d'impact vous
imaginez que cette décision si elle est
effectivement pour parti politique vise
à retrouver une certaine résilience dans
notre mix un meilleur équilibre et
d'ailleurs c'est bien ce sont bien les
perturbations du programme de
maintenance nucléaire en raison de la
crise sanitaire comme parfois du fait
des chaleurs que nous pouvons connaître
pour des raisons de réchauffement
climatique qui expliquent le surcroît de
vigilance dont nous faisons preuve à
certaines périodes de l'automne entre
cinq et dix réacteurs deux de plus que
l'année dernière était à l'arrêt et il
en sera de même certaines périodes cet
hiver les deux réacteurs de fessenheim
n'aurait pas été suffisant à eux seuls
pour changer la donne est en outre cette
centrale aurait nécessité vous le savez
pour continuer à fonctionner de manière
sûre au delà de cette année des
investissements très lourds et massifs
pour assurer cette sûreté ces
investissements importants pour une
contribution faible à
l'approvisionnement se serait fait au
des primes au détriment du déploiement
d'autres capacités de production de
puissance bien plus importante
le nucléaire demande de la planification
c'est ce qui a présidé à l'arrêt de
cette centrale est et nous poursuivrons
en ce sens je veux redire ici que nous
utilisons également de moins en moins
nos centrales à charbon que les
dernières seront arrêtés horizon 2022
conformément à nos engagements nous les
utilisons encore à la marge en source
d'appoint pour faire face à des pics de
consommation sur la période 2010 9 2020
l'utilisation de ce moyen de production
a été sensiblement plus basse que lors
de la période 2015 2018 ainsi la
production sur les mois de septembre
octobre 2020 a été deux fois plus faible
que les années passées je rappelle en
outre que sur la période 2012 2018
nous avons fermé 10 gigawatts de
capacités de production charbon et au
fioul
alors non en aucun cas la fermeture de
fessenheim ne nous conduit à augmenter
notre utilisation de charbon notre
électricité reste de fait la plus
décarbonés d'europe grâce à notre parc
nucléaire
grâce au parc hydraulique et au
développement des os
énergies renouvelables l'épisode actuel
nous montre plus que jamais la nécessité
de diversifier notre mix électrique pour
ne pas dépendre d'une seule source
d'énergie pour renforcer la résilience
du réseau c'est bien cela l'objectif que
nous poursuivons à travers le
développement des énergies renouvelables
comme prévu par la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie qui vise
d'ici à 2035 à diminuer la part du
nucléaire dans notre mix énergie
électrique à 50 % les énergies
renouvelables elle contribue à la
sécurité de notre système électrique je
le redis et là encore les bilans un
prévisionnel de rte le confirme et
doivent constituer une part croissante
de notre mix électrique l'énergie
éolienne elle a ainsi pu représenter
jusqu'à un tiers de la production
électrique comme ce fut le cas le 27
septembre dernier et cette production
éolienne est en moyenne plus élevés en
hiver puisque les conditions climatiques
s'y prête lorsque la consommation
elle-même est plus importante
vous le voyez donc mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs nous sommes prêts et sans
crainte à faire tout à fait face à cette
période hivernale je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre dans la suite
du débat à chaque orateur dispose de
deux minutes maximum pour présenter sa
question avec une réponse du
gouvernement pour une durée équivalente
dans le cas où l'auteur et la question
souhaite répliquer il dispose de 30
secondes supplémentaires à condition que
le temps initial de deux minutes n'est
pas été dépassées et c'est monsieur
pierre mais des villes de medieval
pardon du groupe indépendant qui
inaugure cette séance de questions la
ministre mes chers collègues en 2002 35
de cap fixé est de porter la part du
nucléaire à 50% dans notre mix
électrique changement véritable
stratégie ou simple communication
cette décision ne doit cependant pas
nous mener à ouvrir des sites production
d'énergie polluants ou importer une
énergies carbonées deux pays voisins en
cas demande sur notre propre réseau
nucléaire fait partie des énergies les
moins carbonées et reste encore la plus
stable entre les positions même si je
crois beaucoup aux possibilités qu'offre
d'énergies renouvelables notamment quand
elles sont couplés en stockage par
batterie comme le solaire le prouvant
cette décision ne doit pas non plus
fragilisé notre raison face aux
nouvelles consommations électriques
à titre d'exemple en 2035 plus de 15
millions de véhicules électriques pour
circulez dans l'hexagone j'espère aussi
voir un maillage suffisant pour les
véhicules à hydrogène
ces millions de véhicules électriques
représentent d'après les chiffres la
commission de régulation de l'énergie et
de rte
une consommation annuelle estimée autour
de 35 watts heure soit environ 7% de la
consommation française globale
fort heureusement ces besoins nouveaux
sont compensées par des innovations
permettant de faire baisser la
consommation électrique
j'aimerais aller plus loin et poser la
question en cas de pic de consommation
et donc de risque de tensions
importantes sur le réseau pouvant
entraîner un black out le véhicule
électrique doit être la solution de
gestion intelligente du réseau
ce que l'on appelle la solution novell
cloud grit autrement dit la voiture au
réseau est en train d'émerger
la perspective de pouvoir piloter la
recharge des véhicules électriques est
source d'espoir et d'efficacité du
raison madame la ministre
comment envisagez-vous de faciliter
l'expérimentation et le développement du
pilotage de la recharge des véhicules
électriques dans le potentiel
d'innovation pour y rendre plus flexible
notre réseau et prévenir d'éventuels
black out sur le long terme
madame la ministre merci madame la
présidente mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur médeville
alors la politique pour le mix 2035 plus
tiendra compte des besoins nouveaux et
oui il faudra gérer cette charge
intelligemment pour les véhicules
d'ailleurs quelques expérimentations ont
déjà cours en tant que haut marnaise je
le confirme j'ai pu en avoir la
présentation ce sont des perspectives
qui sont extrêmement très très
intéressante puisque nous avons et nous
l'avons évoqué et je vous le redis des
variations et notre mix énergétique doit
absolument être être diversifiée et
toute mesure qui pourrait favoriser à la
fois
de nouveaux process en termes de
stockage de l'énergie et notamment dans
les mobilités est tout à fait
intéressant à retenir
nous aurons donc une attention toute
particulière à ce principe qui est à
développer dans la mobilité
je remercie monsieur mais de vieilles 40
secondes oui écoutez je madame la
ministre je partage votre optimisme
quant à ces nouvelles voies
d'intelligence de deux raisons
évidemment elle se pose toujours ce
problème et sur lequel nous avançons du
stockage de l'énergie
moi je vois qu'on a pu observer dans
certains coins où la demande n'est pas
trop forte je pense une nouvelle
calédonie avec des deux unités de
cellules photovoltaïques couplée à des
batteries où on arrive presque à une
autonomie ce qui l'attristé largué en
fonction des horaires et c'est vrai que
ça aurait vraiment de nouvelles
perspectives notamment avec les
véhicules ou avec d'autres appareils qui
permettrait de relarguer l'électricité
ont fait confiance au génie français
pour développer ses solutions
merci la parole est un monsieur thomas
de suspens le groupe écologie s'est
arrêtée territoire merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues meier veut aussi à tous et à
toutes
donc rte a activé son dispositif
d'alerté rouge ecowatt vendredi dernier
la tension dans l'approvisionnement
électrique provient d'une part de
l'augmentation de là commence la
consommation liée à la vague du froid
mais elle questionne évidemment notre
mix énergétique celui du tout nucléaire
dont on nous a vanté la soi-disant
robustesse encore à l'instant or la
crise qu vide a encore une fois été
révélatrice de nos vulnérabilités et
cette fois ci en matière énergétique
puisque la dca les ateliers de plusieurs
travaux sur quatre sur plusieurs
réacteurs à peu près quatre sur dix qui
se sont trouvés ainsi à l'arrêt le parc
nucléaire français va bientôt fêter ses
40 ans et représente 77 % du mix
électrique français la voilà la
fragilité notre modèle
loin des discours rassurant et optimiste
c'est celle d'une réalité d'une énergie
coûteuse fragile dangereuse et dépassée
qui n'est pas à la hauteur des enjeux de
notre siècle
mais le génie français ne serait rien
sans son entraînement puisque lorsque de
nombreux pays ont fait le choix de la
diversification nous nous avons fait le
choix d'investir des eps comme suit
flamanville qui affiche déjà dix ans de
retard et dont les coûts sont passés de
3 à 10 9 milliards dont quand j'entends
qu'on n'a pas encore assez investi dans
le nucléaire
j'ai quelques doutes cette peur du
blackout doit permettre donc à certains
d'ouvrir les yeux sur notre mix
énergétique mais aussi à diversifier et
à le rendre à notre à rendre notre mix
plus résilient mais la production n'est
que la moitié du problème il faut aussi
se pencher sur la consommation et donc
sur notre sobriété le secteur du
bâtiment résidentiel et tertiaire
représente aujourd'hui 45 constant de la
consommer la consommation finale
d'énergie en france la part immense du
chauffage électrique couplé à un grand
nombre de passoires thermiques
représente une immense marge de
manoeuvre pour faire baisser la
consommation et à ses recettes ses
réserves d'énergie s'ajoute un l'aider d
un débat nécessaire sur les nouveaux
usages
à ce titre le rapport sur la 5g du haut
commissaire au climat est édifiant
puisqu'il il prévoit leur l'explosion de
la consommation donc ma question est la
suivante à la ministre
quel est votre scénario concrets de
réduction de la consommation électrique
française quelle est votre stratégie en
matière de sobriété
madame la ministre merci mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur dessus alors effectivement les
clés sont dans l'efficacité énergétique
et la maîtrise de la demande
la loi prévoit une diminution de la
consommation d'énergie finale de 20% à
horizon 2030 par rapport à 2012 et il
est prévu une consommation d'électricité
stables à cet horizon par rapport à
aujourd'hui
l'électrification croissante des usagers
temps compensé par une plus grande
efficacité énergétique
alors quel dispositif mettons nous en
oeuvre pour améliorer cette efficacité
énergétique bien sûr la rénovation
thermique est un élément essentiel comme
le renouvellement des modes de chauffage
qui sont aujourd'hui moins carbonées et
plus efficace nous avons pour ce faire
les certificats d'économie d'énergie
l'essai de ce le dispositif marine
rénove qui monte en puissance vous
l'avez vu et les aides de l'anah qui
constituent le coeur des aides à la
rénovation
ces certificats d'économies d'énergie
ont été renforcées au printemps 2020
pour la rénovation des logements et
locaux tertiaires chauffées au fioul et
au gaz notamment est l'ambition de la
cinquième période d'obligations qui
débutera le 1er janvier 2022 est en
cours de définition
ses études elle montre par ailleurs
qu'un remplacement à grande échelle du
chauffage fuel
pour des pompes à chaleur renforce en
renforçant l'isolation n'engage pas
d'augmentation ni de perte
je remercie monsieur dessus s'il vous
reste trente deux secondes on comprend
pas bien quand on quand on parle de
sobriété à quoi à quoi ça sert d'un côté
produire faire des économies d'énergie
forte comme vous le préconisez et
l'autre côté de laisser se développer
les nouveaux usages rappelle la 5g c'est
une augmentation de 2 entre 5 et 13 % de
la consommation finale d'électricité du
résidentiel tertiaire actuelle donc sont
faits les économies d'un côté en isolant
les bâtiments et qu'on laisse se
développer des usages qui font exploser
la consommation électrique
on n'y gagne rien la parole est à madame
nadège à 20 pour le groupe durant
fondement progressiste et indépendant
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues d'abord tous mes
meilleurs voeux pour cette nouvelle
année qui démarre
je constate que le groupe l'est
républicain choisit d'utiliser
l'anglicisme black out énergétique
aussi je rappelle en français qu'il
s'agit d'une coupure généralisée de
l'approvisionnement en électricité sur
tout ou partie d'un territoire
cette crainte a été largement relayée
par les médias en raison des effets de
la crise sanitaire et du confinement du
printemps le calendrier de maintenance
du parc nucléaire est en été retardé par
un nombre anormalement hautes de
réacteurs à l'arrêt le débat de cet
après midi porte donc d'une part sur le
risque de sous production par rapport à
une demande en forte hausse liée à la
chute actuelle des températures et
d'autre part sur les mesures que prend
ou pourrait prendre le gouvernement pour
prévenir ce phénomène dans cette période
hivernale et de couvre feu en france il
est vrai nous sommes particulièrement
consommateurs de chauffage électrique ce
qui peut provoquer une demande rapide en
énergie
au coeur de l'hiver notamment en début
de soirée alors que nos voisins
connaissent d'effroi glaciaux qui
pourrait selon certains scénarios
atteindre la métropole
je souhaiterais que en tant que membre
du groupe d'amitié avoir une pensée pour
l'espagne alors que la tempête philomena
a déjà causé plusieurs décès et qu'une
vague de froid sans précédent depuis
1956 s'abat sur le pays
dans ce contexte pour répondre à une
éventuelle surconsommation des campagnes
de sensibilisation sont lancés et des
mesures existent
en france pour compenser les manques de
ressources tout d'abord la plus connue
et l'importation d'électricité auprès
des pays frontaliers mais la situation
risque d'être tendue car l'allemagne est
elle aussi concernée par cette vague de
froid et sera également soumise à une
forte demande sur son réseau intérieur
dans certains cas extrêmes et rte peut
également demander aux différents
gestionnaires du réseau de distribution
de réaliser des coupures localisées
tournante de maximum deux heures la
bretagne et le sud est de la france
seraient particulièrement touchés par le
délestage du fait d'un faible niveau de
production d'électricité dans ces zones
cette possibilité est elle envisageable
je vous remercie madame la ministre en
merci madame la présidente mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice avait effectivement dans les
situations exceptionnelles ou la
capacité de production pourrait être
insuffisante au regard de la
consommation des mesures post marché
vous venez de le rappeler peuvent être
mobilisés pour éviter d'avoir recours à
des délestages et en particulier
l'activé l'activation des contrats
d'intérim tibi lité des grands
consommateurs industriels qui permettent
à rte de couper son approvisionnement
avec un très faible préavis ces
industriels ils sont rémunérés pour ce
service
la baisse de tension sur les réseaux est
également possible avec une baisse
temporaire de 5% de la tension les
conséquences sur la qualité du service
sont quasiment imperceptible
l'augmentation ponctuelles de nos
importations peut également être une
réponse au delà du signal donné par le
marché et il est également possible et
vous l'avez rappelé de faire appel aux
gestes citoyens
c'est l'objet de tout le site ecowatt
développé avec rte et l'ademe ces
alertes
elles permettent effectivement une
mobilisation et je crois que tous les
trous tous les français peuvent y
trouver du sens il s'agit simplement de
s'adapter et d'habitués certaines 2
d'adapter certaines de nos habitudes du
quotidien pour répondre à cette à cet
appel est d'ailleurs le résultat a été
très bénéfique jeudi dernier et nous
pouvons les en remercier et puis en
dernier recours et seulement si les
leviers ci dessus ne sont pas efficaces
rte prévoit également de pouvoir faire
appel aux délestages tournants cette
possibilité de procéder à une coupure
temporaire de certains clients pour deux
heures en faisant tourner
géographiquement ces coupures
ainsi la situation est maîtrisée et
anticiper en épargnant évidemment les
infrastructures prioritaires comme les
établissements de santé les
installations indispensable à la
sécurité
il ne s'agit surtout pas de mettre la
france dans le noir mais simplement de
maîtriser ce délestage ciblé d'une
partie des consommateurs qui permet
d'éviter des coupures beaucoup plus
profonde
sachant que ces opérations font l'objet
d'une d'une alerte et d'une annonce dès
la veille de ce délestage c'est donc sur
la base de cet effort volontaire de
réduction des éco gestes et de ces
différentes mesures que nous nous
garantissons une absence de black out au
mes chers collègues que je suis
particulièrement heureuse de saluer en
route non on entre non la présence dans
notre tribune d'honneur d'une délégation
de parlementaires libyen conduite par
monsieur aguila saleh président de la
chambre des représentants de libye la
délégation effectue une visite au sénat
à l'invitation du président gérard
larcher
elle sera reçue en audience par le
président du sénat aujourd'hui le
président guy la salle et s'exprimera
également devant la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées
la libye connaît depuis 2011 une
situation politique économique et
sécuritaire complexe
cette situation affecte au premier chef
le peuple libyen mais aussi l' équilibre
de la région et au delà celui du
continent européen
pour y faire face et trouver une issue
favorable la france ne ménage pas ses
efforts
la libye et les libyens savent qu'ils
peuvent compter sur notre appui pour
soutenir les efforts de la médiation
menée sous l'égide des nations unies en
vue de l'instauration d'un état
réunifiée se dit pleinement souverain et
la tenue d'élections le 24 décembre 2021
nous formons le voeu que cette visite
conforte les relations entre nos deux
pays et contribuent à cette sortie de
crise en libye
nous souhaitons au président de la
chambre des représentants monsieur
aguilas aller aux parlementaires et à la
délégation qui accompagne la bienvenue
au sénat de la république française
ainsi qu'une agréable et fructueuse
visite
[Applaudissements]
et la parole est maintenant aux
présidents jean claude requier merci la
présidente madame amis ses collègues
l'accueil est salutaire entraîné des
retards dans la maintenance des
réacteurs nucléaires et donc une moindre
disponibilité du parc
bien que planifier la fermeture de
fessenheim en 2009 1 qui produisait
mille 800 mégawatts d'électricité mais
arrêt des centrales au fioul ou charbon
participeront aux tensions de l'offre en
vérité la centrale de fessenheim nous
manque
si le riz que le black out sera maîtrisé
cet hiver il ne peut être écarté à venir
je remercie les auteurs du débat d'avoir
inscrit ce sujet à l'ordre du jour il
est impératif d'anticiper et d'accroître
les marges de valeur car il n'est pas
acceptable se satisfaire les capacités
d'effacement et de coupures
d'électricité aussi courte soit elle
qu'on sera peut-être le cas au cours du
prochain mois
au delà la nécessaire maîtrise la
demande par des gains d'efficacité
énergétique comme bien de garantir la
stabilité du système électrique
le développement des capacités de
stockage doit s'accélérer afin
d'accompagner l'effort de stabilisation
des réseaux à ce titre locaux à
l'hydrogène constitue un levier
flexibilité pour assurer la sécurité
d'approvisionnement à l'énergie ainsi
qu'une intégration des énergies
renouvelables pour rappel les énergies
renouvelables devraient représenter 40%
du mixeur et qu'il fallait en 2030
la stratégie nationale pour le
développement de l'hydrogène ambitieuse
d'un point de vue financier avec 17
milliards qui sont consacrés et voir que
timidement le stockage de l'énergie
puisque la phrase les stratégies
américaines britanniques la corde une
importance particulière à la résilience
des réseaux les rhétiques à travers le
stockage souterrain de l'hydrogène dès
lors comment le ghana en tête d'y
accélérer le développement du stockage
massif de l'hydrogène
afin d'accompagner la transition
énergétique et préserver la sécurité
d'approvisionnement de notre pays dans
la ministre
merci madame la présidente mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur et qui est alors à court terme
les analyses de rte ne montre pas de
besoin de recours à l'hydrogène pour
faire face aux pointes de consommation
les sources actuelles de flexibilité
sont suffisantes à horizon 2030 2035
pour autant l'objectif prioritaire du
développement de l'hydrogène et la
décarbonation des usages pour pouvoir
l'utiliser directement notamment dans
l'industrie et la mobilité lourde de
manière complémentaire aux solutions
entièrement électrique et à ce titre la
stratégie hydrogène française qui a été
annoncé en septembre dernier par le
gouvernement fixe un objectif de 6,5
gigawatts d'électrolysé horizon 2030
nous nous donnons ainsi la possibilité
de massifier la production et
l'utilisation d'hydrogène avec une
enveloppe de 7 milliards jusqu'à 2030
dont deux dans le plan de relance donc
nous donnant des moyens conséquents pour
pour développer l'hydrogène au delà de
2035 indépendamment du mix électrique
choisi les études montrent un besoin de
stockage accrue et l'hydrogène pourra
alors offrir une solution qui est des
plus intéressantes
plusieurs études prospectives de long
terme sont en cours et permettront de
quantifier ce besoin et plus largement
documenté les enjeux et les leviers de
notre futur système électrique notamment
le bilan prévisionnel 2050 de rte qui
doit être publié à la mi 2021
merci merci monsieur roquet non la
parole est donc maintenant monsieur
fabien gay pour le groupe crc 1 la
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues depuis deux ans rte alerte sur
le risque de tensions du système
électrique durant les hivers à venir et
les risques de coupure généralisée en
novembre dernier madame la ministre
pompili nous confirmer la possibilité de
coupures très courte en cas de grosse
vague de froid
pour y remédier il suffisait selon elle
d'avoir recours à l'effacement
c'est-à-dire de demander aux industries
d'arrêter leur production à certains
moments contre rémunération or demain
ce n'est plus seulement aux entreprises
électro-intensifs que l'on me demandera
de s'effacer mais aussi aux particuliers
grâce aux boîtiers linky
c'est dans cette même logique
semble-t-il que des f a lancé sa
scandaleuse campagne hashtag mais ton
pull alors que 12 millions de personnes
sont déjà en situation de précarité
énergétique
mais tous n'auront pas à se couvrir et
l'hiver ne sera pas rigoureux pour tout
le monde
nous songeons en particulier à 20 la
famille mulliez avait le développement
via des fonds publics du boîtier
d'effacement voltalis cette injonction à
mettre son pull discours paternaliste et
infantilisant présupposant que les
français gaspille ne saurait en aucun
cas masquer votre inertie à développer
une politique industrielle ambitieuse
pour répondre aux besoins de la nation
car le problème c'est que si la crise
épidémique a accentué les menaces sur
l'approvisionnement c'est la
libéralisation du secteur de l'énergie
qui en est à l'origine
et la situation risque fort de devenir
structurel avec le projet recul
aujourd'hui des centrales nucléaires et
à charbon sont fermés sans que le
rapport ne soit compensée et les
barrages hydroélectriques qui sont les
sources d'énergie les plus pilotable qui
permettent d'assurer l'approvisionnement
de façon continue avec le nucléaire
pourrait être confiée demain au privé or
en ce cas nous serions pleinement la
merci des actionnaires qui pourraient
bien décider comment le californie dans
les années 2000 de couper l'alimentation
une question simple quand allez vous
arrêter votre politique mortifère de
libéralisation du secteur de l'énergie
et enfin créer un véritable service
public de l'énergie dans la nation a
besoin et je vous redis madame la
ministre
puisque vous parlez des salariés arrêter
de casser leur statut plus que de longs
discours c'est ce qu'ils attendent de
vous madame la ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur les monsieur le
sénateur gay les producteurs d'énergie
offrent leur production en fonction des
signaux économiques
c'est indéniable et dans le cas d'un
barrage hydroélectrique à réservoir les
producteurs ont une incitation
économique à produire lorsque le prix
est le plus élevé c'est à dire lorsque
les des pointes de consommation
s'annonce ce système il contribue donc à
la sécurité d'approvisionnement quelle
que soit l'option retenue pour le
renouvellement des concessions
hydroélectriques
ce comportement il est dicté par une
rationalité économique et il ne changera
pas la commission de régulation de
l'énergie qui est une autorité
administrative indépendante contrôle par
ailleurs que les acteurs n'abusent pas
de leur éventuel pouvoir de marché nous
avons de plus un gestionnaire de réseaux
de transport rte qui a la responsabilité
d'assurer l'équilibré entre l'offre et
la demande sur ce réseau il a la
possibilité de faire appel aux moyens de
production en cas de risques sur la
sécurité d'approvisionnement
un scénario à la enron ou un acteur
avait pu manipuler le système électrique
grâce à sa possession à la fois de
lignes haute tension crucial pour la
californie et de beaucoup de moyens de
production n'est donc pas à craindre en
france et nous y veillerons plus
largement et ce sera évoquée aussi lors
du débat que vous avez demandé à
organiser demain sur l'évolution de zdf
le gouvernement est très attentif à
mettre en place un dispositif dans
lequel les concessions hydroélectriques
pourront jouer tout leur rôle dans la
transition énergétique comme dans la
gestion de l'eau par exemple laisser la
question des des étiages qui en est un
parfait exemple en développement des
approches cohérentes par vale et en
créant des conditions d'investissement
nouvelles sur les concessions existantes
je remercie merci monsieur le président
longeau c'est à vous président chers
collègues un black out énergétique
traduirait un déséquilibre sur le réseau
et qu'une demande d'électricité
supérieure à la capacité de production à
ce jour un tel déséquilibre ne s'est
jamais produit en france
malheureusement ce risque ne doit pas
être écartée
tant à court terme avec
l'indisponibilité cet hiver de centrale
nucléaire qu'à long terme avec le
rééquilibrage progressif du mix
énergétique de la france en faveur des
énergies renouvelables
le niveau des énergies renouvelables
dans le mix est encore trop faible pour
que leur intermittence et un impact
structurel structurelles sur le réseau
mais cette problématique devrait se
poser de plus en plus à la faveur de
leur développement
quelles solutions peuvent alors être
envisagé de levier principaux sont à
disposition des pouvoirs publics
le dimensionnement des moyens de
production pour faire face à des pics de
consommation d'une part et la
flexibilité du système électrique
d'autre part concernant la flexibilité
il nous faudra bien entendu améliorer
les technologies de stockage de
l'électricité renouvelable intermittente
en la matière madame la ministre
cette solution vous semble aujourd'hui
les plus avancées nous considérons qu'à
long terme le développement d'une
filière d'hydrogène bas carbone pourrait
contribuer à remédier à l'intermittence
saisonnière des énergies renouvelables
l'hydrogène produit en période ne
surplus d'électricité renouvelable par
exemple en été pourrait être stockée
retransformé en électricité par le biais
de piles à combustible ou de turbines à
combustion
pendant les périodes de faible
production éolienne ou solaire le
recours au stockage par hydrogène
devrait cependant demeurer marginal en
france métropolitaine dans les années à
venir du fait du niveau encore modérée
des énergies renouvelables dans le mix
énergétique à long terme d'entrées
énergies renouvelables occuperont une
part plus ambitieuse d'un autre mix ne
faudra-t-il pas faire de l'hydrogène un
outil de flexibilité et je vous remercie
madame la ministre
merci madame la présidente mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président lugo alors à court
terme les analyses de rte ne montre pas
de
besoin de recours supplémentaire au
stockage pour faire face aux pointes de
consommation les sources actuelles de
flexibilité sont suffisantes à horizon
2030 2035
au delà de 2035 indépendamment du mix
électrique choisi les études montrent un
besoin de flexibilité accrue vous l'avez
dit plusieurs leviers sont envisageables
pour fournir cette flexibilité le
développement du stockage
l'amélioration de l'efficacité
énergétique évidemment un meilleur
pilotage de la demande pour baisser et
mieux répartir les pointes de
consommation
en ce qui concerne le stockage
l'hydrogène est une option intéressante
et le gouvernement nous l'avons dit a
mis en place un plan hydrogène doté de 7
milliards d'euros à horizon 2030 pour
massifier la production et l'utilisation
de l'hydrogène à court terme la priorité
du développement de l'hydrogène est à la
décarbonation des usages et notamment
dans l'industrie et la mobilité lourde
d'autres solutions existent pour le
stockage comme le recours aux batteries
au sein du système électrique qui de
plus en plus fréquents et dont les
courbes est assez rapidement à moyen
terme le développement de parcs de
batterie pourra donc apporter cette
flexibilité
le développement des véhicules
électriques offrent également une
opportunité d'améliorer sensiblement la
flexibilité du système grâce à des
outils de pilotage de recharge
il est ainsi tout à fait envisageable
d'inciter les utilisateurs à charger
leurs véhicules en milieu de journée
lorsque la production renouvelable est
importante et à restituer en partie
cette énergie au réseau le soir lorsque
les besoins sont importants
je remercie monsieur le premier
président longeau il vous reste 39
secondes
la parole est à franck montaugé pour le
groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains donnent le présidente
madame la ministre chers collègues la
production d'électricité en france ces
évolutions s'inscrivent dans le cadre de
la ppe réviser et de la stratégie
nationale bas carbone de 71% de
production d'électricité d'origine
nucléaire aujourd'hui avec je le
rappelle un impact minime sur le
réchauffement climatique et un coût très
compétitif
nous devons passer à 50% l'an 2035 la
marche est très haute était interrogé
quant à sa faisabilité
edf s'est engagé dans la mise aux normes
post fukushima et le rallongement de la
durée de vie de ces centres de
production dans le cadre de
un carénage pouvez vous fournir madame
la ministre à la représentation
nationale et à la commission des
affaires économiques du sénat
la programmation pluriannuelle des
investissements et de leur financement
traduisant la planification des
investissements et des gros entretien de
production incluant bien entendu les
énergies renouvelables la situation
actuelle du réseau laisse en effet
comprendre que le mécanisme de capacité
en place ne répond pas à la couverture
des risques identifiés ou constater
cette paix pays devrait bien sûr faire
apparaître les investissements planifiés
au regard des risques de black out et
des nécessités d'importation en
situation de crise de fournitures je
constate aussi que le dernier guide
public de rte relatifs à la gestion des
blacks hot remonte à 2004 2004 madame la
ministre
en quoi le projet recul du gouvernement
en démantelant de fait le groupe edf
seconde des énergéticiens au monde et
fleuron de notre souveraineté
industrielle
va-t-il améliorer la prévention des
black out
comment va-t-il permettre d'améliorer la
résilience de la production et des
réseaux de transport et de distribution
face aux aléas climatiques et
technologiques
maintenant la ministre merci madame la
présidente mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur montaugé
alors on a ces projections et ses bilans
qui sont beaucoup plus fréquents que
vous ne l'indiqué et je crois que les
sénateurs comme les députés que j'étais
encore il y a quelques mois nous avons
largement débattue dans le cadre de la
loi climat énergie et de la ppe la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
de ces différents scénarii et des
possibles alors sur les sur les
investissements ils ont été évidemment
mis en regard le débat sur hercules je
n'y reviens pas je crois que vous avez
un rendez vous sur ce sujet
demain ici au sénat nous avons
effectivement parlé des différentes
mesures qui permettent d'éviter un black
hat qui pour l'instant et pour les
raisons précédemment et vie et évoqué ne
présente pas de risque particulier ni
d'urgence à prendre d'autres d'autres
mesures enfin vous le savez
effectivement le parc nucléaire a
présenté une offre qui a été une
disponibilité en tout cas qui a été
historiquement faibles durant l'hiver
2020 2021
nous en connaissons les raisons les
fermetures de centrales à charbon qui
sont envisagées et évoquer ont eu le
temps de se préparer et nous avons
sécurisé cet cet approvisionnement par
d'autre part un autre mix énergétique
qui nous permet d'aborder tout à fait
sereinement les prochaines échéances
y compris en termes de pics de
consommation monsieur montaugé vous avez
50 et une seconde pour l'électricité la
ministre il faut arrêter avec le dogme
mortifère et qui jouent contre nos
intérêts nationaux de la libre
concurrence non faussée
c'est une organisation adaptée aux
monopoles naturels de ce marché
spécifique à nulle autre pareille qui
permettra en réalité la concurrence et
l'émergence même des énergies
renouvelables donc une entreprise
intégrée de la production à la
distribution traiter le projet recul par
voie d'ordonnancé serait également
dessaisir les français de la question du
devenir de cette entreprise qui leur
appartiennent depuis le conseil national
de la résistance
1946 et de charles de gaulle qui en est
à l'origine
merci mais là par les dames christine
lagarde pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci madame la présidente alors madame
la ministre je vais vous poser une
question simple pourquoi avez vous
décidé de fermer fessenheim et notamment
la seconde tranche quoi qu'il en coûte
je vous rappel jusqu'au moment où la
décision initiale de fermeture de
fessenheim a été prise le p r devait
être en service aujourd'hui nous nous
trouvons dans une situation quoi qu'il
en coûte sur le plan économique
depuis le premier rapport du mois
d'avril de rte sur l'équilibré offre
demande d'électricité pour l'hiver 2020
nous savons que notre système électrique
pourra être d
a lyon les actualisations de ce rapport
font état d'une situation moins
alarmante mais pour autant dans la
version du mois de novembre
il est indiqué que la situation fin
janvier et fin février au pendant le
mois de février pourrait être difficile
si nous subissons une vague de froid ce
qui se traduira par des par le recours à
des mécanismes hors marché qui ont des
conséquences sur l'activité économique
c'est une décision quoi qu'il en coûte
sur le plan des émissions de co2 car
contrairement à ce que vous nous avez
dit précédemment on ne peut pas vivre
uniquement avec des moyens intermittents
et l'énergie nucléaire est une écoute
une énergie qui est pilotable est
décarbonée
qu'est ce qui s'est passé je vous donne
un seul exemple le jeudi 10 novembre 10
% de la production d'électricité a été
fait à partir de centrales à gaz
les centrales à gaz et mettre 40 fois
plus de co2 que le nucléaire la centrale
de coordonnées sera en fonctionnement
jusqu'en 2024 ou 2026 contrairement à ce
qui a été voté et nous importons depuis
chez nous depuis chez nos voisins qui
eux ont un mix énergétique beaucoup plus
carbonées que le nôtre c'est aussi une
décision quoi qu'il en coûte pour les
consommateurs si j'en crois un document
de consultation de la commission de la
régulation de l'énergie qui fait état
d'une augmentation des tarifs bleus à
compter du 1er février
notamment parce que les coûts de
production et nos terres les coûts de
matières premières sont plus élevée + 12
% pour le charbon + 9 % pour le gaz et
+20 % pour les quotas de co2 merci
madame la ministre c'est à vous merci
madame la présidente
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs madame
la sénatrice laval alors corde mais
fonctionnera à cause de pardon
donc de fessenheim n'y changerait rien
et j'ai pu le dire en propos introductif
tout à l'heure la france s'est engagée
effectivement dans une transition
énergétique qui repose sur la sobriété
et l'efficacité énergétique sur la
diversification des sources de
production et d'approvisionnement se
cache derrière bruno nous avons avec la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
2019 2028 une ambition qui se confirme
de réduire la part du nucléaire à
hauteur de 50% à horizon 2035 en
annonçant notamment la fermeture des
deux réacteurs de fessenheim vous
l'avais dit en 2020 le premier ayant été
fermés le 22 février
donc avant la crise et le second en juin
au début de la crise le processus de
fermeture a été quoi qu'il arrive déjà
engagé de manière irréversible
les travaux pour une poursuite de
l'exploitation n'avait pas été fait edf
ne disposait pas du combustible
nécessaire à l'exploitation de la
centrale
la situation à laquelle nous avons fait
face n'est pas la conséquence de la
fermeture de ses deux réacteurs c'est
cet hiver la conséquence de l'arrêt pour
maintenance d'autres réacteurs de
centrales en france cela confirme les
orientations du gouvernement sur le
besoin de diversifier ce mix électrique
pour en améliorer la résilience
notamment contre des événements
extérieurs tels que nous les connaissons
actuellement
par ailleurs madame la sénatrice dois je
vous rappeler le calendrier de le père
de flamanville dont la mise en service
était initialement prévue en 2012 et qui
malheureusement a pris beaucoup de
retard et il ne devrait ne devraient
être opérationnels vraisemblablement
qu'après la mi 2010 23 madame la barre
vous avez 50 et une seconde
oui merci madame la ministre vous nous
avez réexposer des arguments que vous
aviez déjà dû dans votre propre limina
et qui réponde vraiment un parfaitement
à la question puisque la fermeture de la
seconde tranche
au moment où nous étions au mois de juin
les la cause oui mais la première
tranche a été fermée en février je
reviens pas dessus je vous parle bien de
la seconde tranche c'est quand même 900
mégawatts de production de puissants et
là aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous avez à
répondre sur ce qu'on constate à savoir
eu un recours accru aux moyens
thermiques
puisque vous le savez très bien
moyens intermittence seuls ne peuvent
pas suffire pour avoir une production
électrique stable bien la parole est à
madame denise saint-pé pour le groupe
union centriste
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
certains s'inquiètent aujourd'hui un
black out énergétique surviennent en
france cependant un tel scénario ne
pourrait se produire qu'en réduisant
plusieurs conditions
d'une part une forte hausse de la
consommation d'électricité elles mêmes
liées à une baisse durable des
températures et d'autre part une absence
de vent à même d'empêcher le parc éolien
de prendre le relais du parc nucléaire
le risque me paraît donc limité pour le
moment et je compte sur le gouvernement
pour faire en sorte qu'ils ne se
réalisent pas cependant je souhaiterais
aborder la question sur le moyen terme
en réalité des tensions existent déjà
aujourd'hui au moment des pics de
consommation et pourrait bientôt
s'amplifier en effet nos capacités de
production nationales disponibles lors
de ces pointes de consommation risquent
de diminuer à l'avenir puisque 14
réacteurs nucléaires devront être fermés
pour atteindre les objectifs fixés par
la ppe à savoir une part du nucléaire de
50% dans le mix énergétique français
d'ici 2035 ces fermetures devrait être
en principe compensé par un recours
accru aux énergies renouvelables
néanmoins une compensation complète et
efficace laisse dubitatif car ces
sources d'énergie sont par nature
intermittente et produisent moins que le
nucléaire
rajoutant à cette équation le fait que
la r e2020 restreindra de fait
l'utilisation du gaz dans les logements
neufs
cela conduira au retour du chauffage
électrique ce qui risque de solliciter
encore plus nos capacités de productions
d'élèves d'électricité par conséquent
comment pensez vous concilier demain à
la fois la baisse
de la ressource électriques disponibles
au moment des pics de consommation et
l'augmentation plus que probable de la
demande en électricité et ce sans
risquer des black out hivernaux répéter
je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre merci madame la
présidente monsieur les sénateurs madama
sénatrice sempé la politique énergétique
du gouvernement elle va permettre
d'avoir un système électrique plus
diversifiée on l'a dit qui sera donc
plus résilient face aux aléas
l'attention sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement de cet hiver à
l'illustrer il me semble très bien ces
risques d'un système qui ne reposerait
massivement que sur une seule
technologie
cette diversification du mix elle est en
particulier et en particulier dans le
programme de fermeture des réacteurs
dans le développement des énergies
renouvelables qui est ambitieux mais
progressif il ne met pas en péril la
sécurité d'approvisionnement
ce constat il s'appuie sur des analyses
techniques approfondies menées par rte
qui intègre les prévisions d'évolution
de la production de la demande et du
fonctionnement du réseau pour la
production rte intègre la modélisation
d'un très grand nombre de situations
notamment les aléas météo les aléas sur
les moyens de production comme les
retards de maintenance et s'agissant de
la r 20 20 celles ci s'appliquent à des
logements neufs donc ayant une
consommation faible puisque bien isolé
nous mais non nous menons donc une
politique très volontariste de
rénovation des bâtiments existants pour
limiter les besoins de chauffage et le
développement de solutions de chauffage
qui soit peu consommatrices d'énergie
comme les pompes à chaleur la géothermie
les réseaux de chaleur décarbonés sont
évidemment encouragé il n'est ainsi pas
anticipé d'augmentation de la
consommation électrique dans les
prochaines années
or concernant les évolutions au delà de
2035 le ministère la transition
écologique a demandé à l'oeil
rte une étude sur les enjeux liés à
l'intégration massive d'énergies
renouvelables variable dans le système
électrique
les résultats sont très encourageants
ils doivent être publiés sous peu et une
analyse plus détaillée de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement à horizon 2050 doit
être publié à la mi 2021 par rte dans le
cadre de son bilan prévisionnel de long
terme
ces études elles permettront de prendre
des décisions éclairées sur l'évolution
de notre mix après 2035 en toute
connaissance de ces différents enjeux y
compris ceux liés à la sécurité
d'approvisionnement
merci la paroisse l'état madame florence
beatrix comptable pour le groupe
socialiste écologie républicain merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues le spectre du black out
entre régulièrement les colonnes de nos
médias et participent des peurs
collectives récurrente mais dans le cas
précis pour cette année le ce risque
semble relativement contenu même si
l'accident demeurent toujours probable
le rôle du politique en ces moments
d'inquiétude n'est pas d'attiser les
peurs mais quand même de tenter de les
éclairer sur la réalité du risque et
surtout de vrais à une réponse
collective donc l'orientation qui tend à
réduire de façon significative la part
des énergies fossiles dans notre
production électrique est une
orientation qui doit être poursuivi et
prolongé en veillant particulièrement à
réduire le co2 principal responsable du
réchauffement climatique la réduction
des énergies fossiles concerne aussi
l'énergie nucléaire mais qui pour autant
al'avantage de ne pas être aimée
émetteurs de co2 donc on a déjà évoqué
deux lors de ce débat le grand carénage
dont on nous dit qu'il est nécessaire
donc qui est nécessaire pour répondre à
l'impératif de sécurité et de sûreté il
a pris un grand retard avec la pandémie
est ce que vous pouvez en l'état madame
la ministre nous fournir des indications
plus précises sur le calendrier est
projeté je voudrais également revenir
sur la l'aéro 2020 qui prévoit une
sortie rapide des énergies fossiles
excluant progressivement les chaudières
fioul et gaz et vous avez évoqué
l'étude rt ademe sur le sujet qui montre
que cela peut conduire à un
accroissement significatif de la part du
chauffage électrique qui générera une
tension accrue sur le réseau en période
de pointe
donc est ce que le gouvernement entend
avancer dans les voies suggéré par
l'ademe et comment réduire sensiblement
le risque accru de tension du réseau
alors que l'on voit la montée en
puissance forte des de chauffage
électrique et notamment des pompes à
chaleur
madame la ministre la présidente
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs madame
la sénatrice place rex cantat alors
effectivement vous parlez de
responsables ecti vais je vous en
remercie il est effectivement bombe de
partager ses objectifs qu'ils envoient
sans parfois peuvent ce sympathique t
nous avons un objectif commun de
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre la nécessité de garder des
énergies fossiles
là où elles sont désormais des limites à
l'exercice de la production nucléaire
que l'on a vu avec effectivement un
calendrier notamment sur les travaux de
maintenance 2021 2022 qui a glissé des
visites décennales dont les calendriers
s'étale sur deux grands tableur que je
ne pourrais pas vous détailler ici mais
qui sont prévus pour retrouver un rythme
habituel mais soumis à la fois à ses
aléas climatiques comme nous avons pu le
connaître cet été et à des difficultés
liées à la crise sanitaire que nous
venons de traverser
alors ces tensions sur les réseaux cette
nécessité de parvenir à une plus grande
sobriété d'abord énergétique je crois
que c'est c'est une des clés elle se
travaille dans ce grand plan de
rénovation erne énergétique que nous
déployons dans ses modes de chauffage
qui sont aujourd'hui moins énergivore
plus efficace et donc plus sobres en
énergie et tout ce plan doit nous amener
à une consommation relativement stable
qui nous permettent de déployer ce
nouveau mix énergétique en toute
sécurité
merci merci la parole et à monsieur
christian klinger pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci madame la présidente
le 25 novembre dernier j'alertais lors
d'une question d'actualité au
gouvernement sur la situation de tension
du réseau électrique cet hiver le
secrétaire d'état djebbari avait assuré
devant la représentation nationale que
la situation était sous contrôle et
qu'il n'y aurait pas de coupures
d'approvisionnement or vendredi dernier
rte a publié un communiqué incitant les
français à réduire leur consommation
pour éviter tout risque de coupure
d'électricité
ce communiqué précise qu'en cas de
difficultés d'approvisionnement
rte peut avoir recours à des coupures
tournantes cette situation arrive alors
que les deux réacteurs de la centrale de
fessenheim ont été fermées en 2020 et
engendrant une perte 2800 mégawatts dans
le communiqué de rte
il est mentionné le chiffre de 600
mégawatts pour garder une marge de
manoeuvre sur le réseau or un réacteur
de la centrale de fessenheim
c'est 900 mégawatts d'après les données
de rte
nous avons ces derniers jours un recours
accru au charbon avec en moyenne 3 % de
notre production issue de ce charbon et
des importations d'électricité bien plus
importante que la normale
madame la ministre au vu de l'ensemble
de ces éléments est ce que votre
gouvernement n'a pas fermé la centrale
de fessenheim trop tôt c'est à dire
avant la mise en route de l'epr de
flamanville en février la france devrait
connaître une vague de froid pouvez-vous
cette fois à nouveau nous assurer que
nous serons en capacité de faire face à
cet hiver et d hiver prochain
pensez vous que votre stratégie
énergétique et durable alors que nous
émettons beaucoup plus de co2 en ayant
recours au charbon ou au fioul et au gaz
et ne pensez vous pas que votre
stratégie remettre en cause
l'indépendance énergétique de la france
car nous avons recours de manière accrue
aux importations d'électricité notamment
celle produite avec du gaz et du charbon
madame la ministre un
si madame la présidente mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur grainger alors dans le cadre
des lois adoptées en 2015 et 2019 nous
avons effectivement fixé ses objectifs
de décarbonation d'efficacité
énergétique et de diversification du mix
énergétique par les jeunes et les nerfs
à terme en 2035 nous aurons donc dans
l'électricité de l'ordre 40% de nerfs et
de 50% de nucléaire ce qui induira la
fermeture de certains réacteurs parmi
les plus anciens les deux réacteurs de
fessenheim vous l'avez rappelé ont été
fermées en février puis en juin 2020
dans le cadre d'un processus qui étaient
engagés en 2019 et qui était absolument
irréversible
les travaux de sûreté n'était pas fait
edf ne disposait pas du combustible
nécessaire et la situation actuelle que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui
elle résulte d'abord d'une disponibilité
moindre du parc nucléaire du fait de
différents problèmes de maintenance liés
notamment à la crise sanitaire
vendredi dernier alors même que nous
avions une température qui était
inférieur de 4 degrés à la normale
saisonnière nous avons une fille née
seulement besoin de 81 7 gigawatts donc
donc beaucoup moins que prévu
nous avons été loin d'activer les
mesures exceptionnelles que j'ai pu
précédemment évoqué nous agissons donc
en toute sérénité par rapport à ce
risque de rupture d'approvisionnement
que je remercie merci mais cette rigueur
vous avez 33 secondes lors il est vrai
que les consommations sont moindres que
celles prévues n'est pas sans savoir que
la france connaît une situation
économique et que les entreprises ne
tourne pas à plein régime
et ceci expliquant cela je suis allé sur
le site de rte et comics vous le
connaissez aussi bien que moi vous savez
je suis assez factuel nous sommes
aujourd'hui en train de consommer 1981
mégawatt produit par le charbon si
fessenheim étaient encore ouverts nous
aurions fait cette économie en termes de
d'électricité décarbonée
les chiffres sont têtus c'est comme ça
merci la parole et un madame feront un
monsieur dont sarah 10 pour le groupe
cic écologistes et républicains à la
présidence de la ministre mes chers
collègues
madame la ministre de la transition
écologique en novembre dernier en plein
de confinement assuré dans les médias
qu'il n'y aurait pas de black out
énergétique cet hiver en prenant soin
toutefois de préciser que des mesures de
régulation était prévu elles sont très
simples
les français vont devoir se rationner
c'est ce que rta annoncé jeudi dernier
face à la vague de froid qui touche
notre pays et à la hausse attendue de la
consommation d'électricité
pouvez vous nous dire madame la ministre
ce que nos concitoyens doivent faire
lorsqu'ils ont besoin de se chauffer et
en même temps de télétravailler
commandes s'effectuent leur choix
en vérité cette situation dès que le
résultat de l'imprévoyance du
gouvernement qui s'apprête à fragiliser
notre souveraineté énergétique avec son
projet recul les épisodes de confinement
qui ont marqué l'année 2020 et qui
menace de se poursuivre encore en 2021
en fortement sollicité le secteur
énergétique
si le premier confinement avaient
entraîné une baisse relative de la
consommation électrique en raison de la
saison et de la baisse d'activité
globale celui de novembre a enregistré
une hausse de 4% de la consommation les
cris des ménages
ces épisodes ont par ailleurs
considérablement retardé comme cela a
déjà été dit les opérations de
maintenance des centrales nucléaires
d'edf
je rappelle que si la france a pour
objectif louable de diversifier son mix
énergétique énergies renouvelables sont
encore trop intermittente pour remplacer
le nucléaire qui assure donc 70 % des
approvisionnements énergétiques
or l'année 2020 a fait chuter
drastiquement sa production pour la
première fois depuis 30 ans et edf avait
prévenu au printemps que ce retard
pourrait fragiliser notre production
d'électricité pour certains mois de
l'année
précisément nous y sommes et la seule
solution habituelle avec ce gouvernement
est de faire payer aux français le prix
de son imprévoyance en exigeant d'eux
qu'ils réduisent la consommation risque
de surconsommation électrique
d'augmentation du coût des énergies de
conséquences sociales importantes pour
les populations déjà durement touchée
par le chômage partiel aussi ou la
cessation d'activité madame la ministre
quel dispositif avez vous pris
pour répondre à tous ces enjeux madame
la ministre
merci madame la présidente mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur ronan sarrazy alors il n'est
évidemment pas question de rationnement
pour les ménages soyons mesurer cela dit
une forme de sobriété que certains
d'entre nous peuvent s'appliquer à titre
personnel en conscience est tout à fait
imaginable
et quand la contrainte est telle que la
précarité énergétique impose des ce type
de difficultés nous avons effectivement
beaucoup d'aidé vous le savez monsieur
le sénateur pour aider au niveau social
ces ménages ces familles ces personnes à
se chauffer et bénéficier d'un habitat
digne
donc ces dispositifs il existe ces aides
elle existe cette conscience de la
nécessaire maîtrise de notre dépense
énergétique nous la partageons je crois
il n'est évidemment pas question de
priver les français d'un quelconque
confort énergétique
vous savez qu économiquement vouloir se
rassurer en surdimensionnement notre
approvisionnement là où il n'est pas
nécessaire aurait à la fois un impact
néfaste au niveau environnemental comme
économique
à partir du moment où pour l'heure ces
craintes sont infondées
je remercie merci vous il vous reste 33
secondes de monsieur rodolphe arazi
madame la ministre j'ai du mal être
convaincu par vos arguments si le
gouvernement s'était montrée prévoyant
rte n'aurait pas besoin d'exiger un
rationnement de la part des
consommateurs dans un contexte aussi dur
socialement économiquement que celui que
nous traversons il est injuste de
réclamer encore de nouveaux sacrifices
aux français
surtout le lorsqu'ils concernent le
droit élémentaire de se chauffer de
travailler à cet égard le projet recul
est une épée de damoclès qui fragilisera
et des structures à notre modèle
énergétique ce qui au regard des enjeux
en termes de souveraineté n'est pas
acceptable
merci la parole est à madame françoise
dumont pour le groupe l'est républicain
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le 19 novembre
dernier la ministre à la transition
écologique évoqué la possibilité de
coupures très courte de courant durant
l'hiver en cours 2 go en en cas de
grosse vague de froid point de boule de
cristal pour elle mais simplement
l'anticipation de son annonce suivante
en date du 24 novembre lors de la
présentation des principales
orientations de la nouvelle
réglementation pour la construction des
bâtiments neufs appelé air 2020 où elle
annoncé en filigrane la disparition à
moyen terme du chauffage au gaz pour les
constructions neuves en fixant un seuil
d'émission de co2 tellement bas qu'il
rendrait ainsi presque impossible leur
installation dans les maisons
individuelles à partir de lait dès l'été
2021 et pour les logements collectifs à
partir de 2024 ce sont donc désormais
presque uniquement des systèmes de
chauffage électrique qui seront
installés dans tous les futurs logements
neufs accentuant ainsi bien sûr
l'attention sur notre système de
production d'électricité durant les mois
d'hiver
et ceci alors qu'il ya presque un an
comme nous le rappelait justement notre
collègue christian klinger le
gouvernement fermer la centrale
nucléaire encore opérationnels de
fessenheim ce qui se traduit désormais
par l'émission de 10 millions de tonnes
de co2 supplémentaires en europe par an
mais rassurons-nous mes chers collègues
le 4 décembre le président de la
république a assuré lors de son
interview à brut
moi j'assume à fond je crois dans
l'écologie je sois je suis pour qu'on
soit parmi les champions de la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
si on veut réussir ça veut dire qu'on
doit être meilleur encore sur le
nucléaire position renouveler le 8
décembre sur le site de framatome au
creusot saint-hilaire disait il faut que
nous considérions un homme non pas tel
qu'il se fait voir par ses discours mais
tel qu'il se montre par ses actes je
vous le laisse seul juge mes chers
collègues aussi madame la ministre est
devant la représentation nationale
comment pouvez vous nous assurez
clairement qu'il n'y aura pas l avenir
de black out énergétique en france
je vous remercie madame la ministre en
merci madame la présidente mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice d'humains effectivement je le
redis l'analyse de l' équilibre offre
demande qui est effectuée de manière
prospective par rta au travers de ces
bilans prévisionnels ne présentent pas
ne montre pas de risque de black out
plusieurs mesures sont par ailleurs la
disposition du gestionnaire de réseau
rte pour répondre à ces pics de
consommation que nous pouvons connaître
liés aux aléas notamment climatiques le
gouvernement a pris différentes mesures
pour accroître leur disponibilité qu'il
s'agisse de l'effacement ou de
l'interactivité pour le long terme des
études sont en cours entre autres avec
les yeux et rte pour fixer les enjeux de
notre mix après 2035 les parlementaires
ils seront bien évidemment associé ce
qui permettra de définir des stratégies
d'investissement dans la production le
réseau le stockage sans oublier
évidemment la maîtrise de la demande en
tenant compte des enjeux de sécurité
d'approvisionnement concernant la r 20
20 un travail fouillé et conduit pour
affiner les détails des obligations leur
niveau et date avec l'amélioration de la
performance des bâtiments cela va
permettre de déployer des moyens de
chauffage qui soit moins carboné des
pompes à chaleur hybride gaz du
renouvelable des réseaux de chaleur à
nouveau décarbonés et évidemment pas de
déployer des grille-pain tels que nous
avons pu les connaître en d'autres temps
l'étude ademe rte montre qu'avec des
bâtiments bien isolé neufs et existants
et des pompes à chaleur sans problème
sur la pointe électrique nous parvenons
tout à fait à passer ces pics de
consommation
je remercie merci la parole est à
monsieur le sénateur bruno sido
merci madame la présidente le parlement
a voté dans la loi énergie climat
la fermeture des centrales à charbon à
l'horizon 2022 et dans le même temps
depuis le mois de septembre la france à
lui mais ces quatre centrales à charbon
fortement émettrices de co2 pour
compenser en partie l'arrêt de
fessenheim et le manque de vent pour les
éoliennes
depuis septembre aussi à cause de
l'arrêt de cette centrale nucléaire il
arrive à edf de le voir importés très
cher de l'électricité produite au gaz ou
au lignite en allemagne ainsi hier
pendant 24 heures la france à importer
de l'électricité l'équivalent de six
tranches nucléaires
ces mesures successives d'intermittence
hivernale de l'éolien et du solaire
presque absent de la production
électrique française met en danger notre
réseau combiné à la capacité d'edf de
tenir les délais du futur réacteur de
flamanville fragilise la sécurité de
l'approvisionnement électrique
la semaine dernière le gestionnaire du
réseau de transport d'électricité
français rte a demandé aux français de
réduire ses taux jeudi dernier leur
consommation d'électricité face à un
risque de tensions sur notre réseau le
risque de coupures chez les particuliers
n'est pas un acte banal
la france ne saurait s'y habituer face
aux risques d'instabilité de notre
réseau électrique due à notre dépendance
envers les autres pays européens et aux
orientations énergétiques
quel est le nouveau calendrier pour la
mise en service du futur réacteur 2 le p
r de flamanville madame la ministre
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur sido le
gouvernement vous le savez apporte une
attention particulière au calendrier de
mise en service de ce réacteur les
essais à chaud se sont terminés en
février 2020 les premiers assemblages de
combustibles ont été approvisionnés en
octobre pour être entreposés et le
processus de remise à niveau des
soudures situé sur le circuit secondaire
se poursuit le scénario de reprise des
soudures de traverser d'enceinte étant
en cours d'examen par l'asn
malgré la crise sanitaire edf n'a pas
fait connaître de modification de son
objectif de chargement de combustible
fin 2022 le pr2 vrai
selon toute vraisemblance pouvoir être
opérationnel en 2023
je vous remercie monsieur sido il vous
reste 52 secondes dit dans votre merci
madame la ministre pour votre réponse
mais à vrai dire tout votre raisonnement
toutes vos réponses que vous est donné
depuis le début de cette séance c'est
comme s'il n'y avait jamais d'incidents
puis je vous rappeler et que le 4
novembre 2006 dans la soirée 15 millions
de foyers ont été privés d'électricité
dont 5,6 millions en france due à un
incident en allemagne en allemagne ce
qui a amené le sénat a rédigé sous ma
présidence
non pas du sénat mais de la commission
une mission commune d'information sur la
sécurité d'approvisionnement électrique
de la france et les moyens de la
préserver
je vous invite à relire ce rapport il
est très intéressant et en particulier
fait des propositions très concrètes
pour finalement faire en sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas d'incident de ce genre
vous savez les accidents sait jamais
c'est rarement prévisible c'est pour ça
qu'on les appelle des accidents et
n'ayez pas ne soyez pas aussi sûr que
cela si nous allons surmonter cette
crise en 2006 c'est parce que nous
avions des capacités à répondre
disponibles nous n'avons plus
aujourd'hui
comment serait view la parole est à
didier mandelli pour le groupe l'est
républicain
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je souhaite tout
d'abord saluer celui qui est à l'origine
de ce débat notre collègue daniel
grémillet pour sa perspicacité
en effet ces échanges tight point nommé
après la période vécue en fin de semaine
dernière
nous partageons tous l'objectif de mieux
consommer de moins consommer d'énergie
en particulier quand elle est d'origine
fossile
la demande faite aux français de réduire
leur consommation était sans doute
nécessaire compte tenu des ressources
disponibles
elle résonne avant tout comme un aveu
d'échec ou en tout cas d'impuissance à
réguler les flux de notre mix
énergétique sur lequel les orateurs
précédents sont intervenus au moment
nous nous orientons fortement et
positivement vers une économie
décarbonée suppléé par le tout
électrique dans les transports dans le
bâtiment et des besoins croissants du
numérique comme nous le verrons dans
quelques minutes avec la ppl de patrick
chaize
il paraît indispensable d'aborder sans
dogmatisme la question de l'origine de
l'énergie indispensable au
fonctionnement de notre pays dans tous
ses usages
les françaises et les français n'ont pas
à subir des atermoiements successifs des
décideurs publics et les conséquences
des décisions arbitraires parfois
démagogiques qui nous ont conduit à
cette situation potentielle cela ne
serait pas digne d'un grand pays comme
le nôtre du bon sens du réalisme du
pragmatisme une vision simon veut à
l'aube de cette nouvelle année madame la
ministre madame la ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur mandelli un voeu partagé de
résilience de sobriété et d'intelligence
dans la construction nos réponses qui ne
sont sans doute pas uniforme et en tout
cas appelle notre travail collectif
devant cette responsabilité qui est la
nôtre de trouver des solutions pour les
générations futures
la politique énergétique du gouvernement
elle va permettre un système électrique
plus diversifiée vous l'avez dit c'est
une des clés de la résilience face aux
aléas que nous connaissons a mal aux
reins que trop aujourd'hui les tensions
sur la sécurité d'approvisionnement de
cet hiver elle illustre le risque d'un
système qui reposerait massivement sur
une seule technologie et cette
diversification du mix elle est en
particulier au programme de fermeture de
ses réacteurs et du développement
d'énergies renouvelables qui doivent
être ambitieuse mais progressive car ne
devant pas mettre en péril cette
sécurité d'approvisionnement à laquelle
nous sommes attachés ce constat il
s'appuie sur des analyses techniques
approfondies menées notamment par rte
qui intègre les prévisions d'évolution
de la production de la demande et du
fonctionnement du réseau pour la
production rte intègre la modélisation
d'un grand nombre de ces situations nous
l'avons dit et au delà de 2035 une étude
donc mené à l'eeie rte devra nous
éclairer sur ces possibles et sur sur
ces investissements que nous devons
envisager au delà de 2035 les
les perspectives que nous avons sont
plutôt encourageantes
cette analyse détaillée de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement à horizon 2050 qui
doit être publié au milieu de cette
année 2021 par rte dans le cadre de son
bilan prévisionnel doit nous donner les
grands axes de sécurisation de ce mix
énergétique et de notre sécurité
d'approvisionnement concernant la
question essentielle de la décarbonation
rte a estimé que le parc solaire et
éolien a permis d'éviter en 2019 22
millions de tonnes de co2 au niveau
européen cela représente les émissions
annuelles d'environ 12 millions de
véhicules et le développement des er ils
nous permettent donc de réduire ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre je
remercie monsieur il vous reste une
minute 14 résidences et c'est plus est
pendant un an la ministre
voilà je vous le dis on partage les
objectifs
moi je suis assez dubitatif sur sur la
vocation ou la capacité de rte à mesurer
l'évolution globalement on l'a vu il
avait évoqué des uns et les autres dans
le bâtiment les voitures électriques
le numérique je suis pas persuadé qu'on
ait pris la mesure des évolutions très
rapides on le voit dans d'autres pays
sur l'ensemble de ces
ces nouvelles demandes en réalité donc
moi je souhaiterais avec le président de
la commission je soumettrai présent de
la commission aménagement du territoire
mais peut-être aussi avec les ans la
commission écho ici puis avec d'autres
qu'on puisse rencontrer rte
pour connaître les modèles précisément
qui servent à établir ces indicateurs et
ses perspectives
parce que j'ai un peu de doute sur
l'ensemble des mesures qui sont intégrés
pour aboutir cette espèce de deux
positions dire voilà tout va bien tout
est prévu on a tout intégré aujourd'hui
la preuve en est je pense qu'on n'est
pas on n'est pas prêt véritablement
merci la parole et a un fils dépouillé
pour deux minutes dernière dernier
intervenant questionnant avant la
conclusion du débat
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la loi de
2015 sur la transition énergétique a
marqué un tournant dans la politique
énergétique française avec la réduction
à l'horizon 2025 de la part du nucléaire
dans la production d'électricité à
hauteur de 50% objectif repousser à 2035
depuis la loi énergie climat car
totalement irréaliste et voilà comment
par dogmatisme
on réduit notre capacité de production
électrique pilotable est propre à savoir
le nucléaire pour la remplacer par des
énergies tout aussi propre mais
intermittente et aléatoire à savoir les
énergies renouvelables avec pour
conséquence la capacité de couvrir la
consommation des ménages des entreprises
en électricité en cas d'hiver rigoureux
et peut-être dès cet hiver
le gouvernement veut s'appuyer sur
l'électricité d'origine renouvelable
pour pallier celle d'origine nucléaire
mais les voyants sont au rouge les
objectifs de la politique énergétique
nationale risque de ne pas être atteint
le compte d'affectation spéciale
transition énergétique qui assurerait le
financement des nerfs a été supprimé du
budget les dispositifs de soutien aux
nerfs sont entrées dans une zone de
turbulences puisque la baisse des prix
des énergies renchérit les charges de
service public de l'énergie qui les sous
tendent
l'hydroélectricité la première source
d'énergie renouvelable en france est
menacée avec la demande d'ouverture à la
concurrence du secteur par bruxelles
en tous les cas les projets sont à
l'arrêt
les nerfs sont le parent pauvre
également du plan de relance
au total 28 % des objectifs fixés par la
ppe d'ici 2023 ne sont pas réalisés pour
les installations photovoltaïques
éoliennes et hydrauliques
concrètement de madame des mini vans à
la ministre quelle est donc la stratégie
pour le développement des nerfs
électrique et seront elles un jour
suffisante pour pallier le recul de
l'électricité nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique et assurer la continuité du
service
merci mme la présidente mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur mouillé alors la loi le fixe
des objectifs ambitieux de développement
effectivement d énergie nucléaire en
visant 40 % de la production électrique
d'origine renouvelable à l'horizon 2030
pour atteindre cet objectif nous
déployons des dispositifs de soutien
publics pour les énergies renouvelables
en 2021
ce seront plus de 6 milliards d'euros
consacrés à ce soutien
et grâce à cet effort soutenu plusieurs
depuis plusieurs années la compétitivité
des énergies renouvelables notamment
électrique s'est fortement améliorée
puisque avec des prix qui atteignent
maintenant environ 60 euros le mégawatt
lors des derniers appels d'offre solaire
éolien terrestre et même 44 euros pour
le parc éolien en mer de dunkerque
là où je vous le rappelle la creuse
annonce 48 à 50 euros pour le nucléaire
résistants existants et bien plus pour
le nucléaire à venir
nous sommes face à des offres est une
compacte compétitivité tout à fait
évidente des énergies renouvelables
aujourd'hui alors pour rendre crédible
l'atteinte des objectifs de la ppe nous
travaillons effectivement sur tous les
leviers le calendrier des appels
d'offres pluriannuel qui donne aux
acteurs une visibilité leur permettant
de développer leurs projets et leurs
stratégies
nous soutenons l'innovation par le pays
a pour développer les technologies ou
des appels d'offres spécifiques pour les
déployer et nous travaillons sur des
questions de planification et de délais
de raccordement de qualité de la
concertation des projets et de
planification jusque dans
l'appropriation locale puisque vous
savez que c'est un enjeu a fortiori dans
nos territoires
les études techniques approfondies qui
sont menées par rte elle montre que la
diversification du mix et les
électriques prévus par la loi et en
particulier
en cadre du programme de fermeture de
réacteur et du développement de ces
énergies renouvelables ne met pas en
péril la sécurité d'approvisionnement à
moyen terme et ses évolutions elles
seront évoqués dans l'étude qui doit
être publié à la mi 2021 par rte
notamment sur cette sécurité
d'approvisionnement de formation mais
monsieur mouillez-vous rêve 38 secondes
en merci mais la présidente j'entends le
l'ensemble de vos arguments vous avez lu
la fiche vous donnant toutes les
explications mais très concrètement
c'est le problème de l' équilibre
l' équilibre entre la volonté d'éliminer
le nucléaire et la capacité à produire à
faire par les énergies renouvelables et
aujourd'hui on a on constate une
difficulté une vraie difficulté
d'ailleurs parce que je rappelle les
renouvelables ne sont pas toujours
maîtrisable et donc que dès lors qu'on
n'est pas capable de stocker il faut
avoir une évaluation qui soit différente
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui la situation
que nous vivons est au main event liés à
une mauvaise évaluation de cette
capacité à réduire le nucléaire deuxième
point également lorsque vous êtes sur le
terrain dans les territoires moi je suis
membre d'un scénic électricité on
constate que finalement aujourd'hui
entre les comptes administratifs les
politiques financières et les gérer la
conduite des projets nous sommes en
vraie difficulté
il ya un vrai frein qui est constatée
sur les territoires sur la capacité à
produire et à faire et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui entre votre vision
technique et je crois comprendre au
niveau national et la réalité il ya un
vrai décalage
en tous les cas madame la ministre est
un point essentiel de notre débat de cet
après midi merci la parole pour la
conclure ce débat est un monsieur
stéphane gay noir pour le groupe l'est
républicain et pour cinq minutes
donc madame la ministre cheikh collègues
comment en est on arrivé là c'est sans
doute la question qui est venu à
l'esprit un certain nombre d'entre nous
lorsque rte a demandé aux français
vendredi dernier de réduire leur
consommation pour éviter des coupures
d'électricité sur l'ensemble de notre
territoire
je salue donc la pertinence de
l'initiative de mon groupe l'est
républicain qui a tenu à faire ce débat
aujourd'hui mais je regrette l'absence
de réponse concrète de votre part madame
la ministre celui janvier donc la
situation climatique est elle si
rigoureuse et les besoins prévisionnels
était-il si exceptionnel pour craindre à
ce point un black out
en réalité non les températures
affichait seulement quelques valeurs
légèrement négative et le pic de la
demande était estimée à 80 8 gigawatts
très loin du maximum historique du 8
février 2012 à hauteur de 100 2
gigawatts donc rien qui ne devraient a
priori effrayer un pays comme la france
à bien y réfléchir nous retrouver en
telle difficulté est assez inouïe car il
ne s'agit pas d'une énergie fossiles
comme le pétrole ou le gaz dont notre
sol national est quasiment dépourvue
d'une énergie pour laquelle notre pays a
savamment construit une stratégie
d'autonomie dès les années 60 et
l'absence de décisions anticipatrice et
les renoncements sur l'autel de petits
arrangements politiques ont mis à mal
cette souveraineté basé sur une avance
technologique reconnue dans le domaine
du nucléaire
quelques-uns dont la ministre de la
transition écologique évoque la
possibilité de se tourner radicalement
vers d'autres sources d'électricité et
caresse même l'espoir d'un mix
totalement renouvelable à l'horizon 2050
mais d'autres sont nettement plus
sceptiques et partage l'analyse de
l'ancien député socialiste jean yves le
déaut qui déclarait en 2017 en sa
qualité de président de l'opex je le
cite le développement de la puissance
éolienne et photovoltaïque installé ne
contribue pas à assurer la sécurité
d'approvisionnement en tout cas pas dans
la période de points
la plus critique c'est-à-dire celle du
soir
et les chiffres sont têtus lors de cette
fameuse journée du 8 janvier les deux
sources éoliens et photovoltaïques n'ont
jamais au meilleur de la journée n'ont
jamais excéder 5% du total
quelles que soient les rêves des uns et
des autres notre géographie naturel
n'est pas celle de la norvège et ne nous
permet pas de remplacer notre capacité
de production par des sources
intermittentes et non pilotable au
contraire il faut avoir le courage de le
dire aux français nous importons
régulièrement de l'énergie très
fortement carbonées en raison notamment
de la baisse de notre production de
nucléaire liée à la fermeture des deux
réacteurs de fessenheim
certes plusieurs pistes prometteuses ont
été évoqués durant ce débat les systèmes
de stockage par batterie la production
d'hydrogène vert mais dans le même temps
on abandonne le programme astrid sur les
réacteurs nucléaires de quatrième
génération
alors que d'autres pays accélère alors
dans l' équilibre recherché pour éviter
un black out la solution viendra-t-elle
du côté de la demande
malheureusement non la représentation
nationale a par exemple pris la décision
d'interdire la commercialisation des
véhicules émettant des gaz à effet de
serre à l'horizon 2040
sans vouloir revenir sur ce débat
admettons que cela devrait renforcer et
favoriser le véhicule électrique et donc
augmenter la consommation dans les
prochaines années de l'ordre de 15%
d'ici 2040
et le réflexe naturel des propriétaires
est bien de brancher leur véhicule
en rentrant du travail précisément au
moment du pic de consommation tandis que
les 30 mille bornes de recharge
publiques sont elles aussi davantage
sollicités en journée en juillet dernier
autre exemple le gouvernement a annoncé
la fin des chaudières fonctionnant au
fuel et plus récemment la réglementation
environnementale vavin prévu dans la loi
elle en prévoit d'interdire le chauffage
au gaz dans les nouvelles constructions
immobilières de facto cela se traduira
par une orientation vers des solutions
consommatrices d'électricité au premier
rang desquels on trouve les pompes à
chaleur
par ailleurs une récente étude du
cabinet ihs tubes et de l'institut
d'économie de cologne montre qu'une
vague de froid
rigoureux en europe pourrait conduire à
un déficit de capacité de production de
35 à 70 gigawatts et des coupures
d'électricité 200 à 250 heures autre
facteur de nature à tendre le réseau
durant les vagues de chaleur comme l'été
dernier en californie
l'utilisation de climatiseurs pouvant
représenter jusqu'à 70% de la
consommation en secteur résidentiel
enfin les usages numériques continuent à
croître de manière importante avec les
smartphones et le stockage sur le cloud
mais aussi le télétravail et les
visioconférences que le confinement a
nettement renforcé en synthèse au moment
même où la demande est sur une tendance
haussière incontestable et durable notre
pays a choisi de réduire ses moyens d'y
répondre de manière opérationnelle
devant ce sentiment d' absurde je
termine sur cette réflexion de jacques
rouxel le célèbre parolier des shadoks
en essayant continuellement ont fini par
réussir donc plus ça rate on a de
chances que ça marche
[Musique]